>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CHARLESTON.
HAPPY FRIDAY.
CARLSON IN 2016 A PHENOMENA
APPEARED AND IN THE POLITICAL
POLLS DONALD TRUMP SEEMED TO BE
PERFORMING EXCEPTIONALLY WELL
AMONG HISPANIC VOTERS IN
FLORIDA.
IT WAS BIZARRE.
SO BIZARRE EVERYONE KNEE IT
COULD NOT BE HAPPENING AND WAS
SCIENTIFICALLY IMPOSSIBLE.
ONE THING THAT EVERY O REPORTER
IN AMERICA UNDERSTOOD WAS THAT
DONALD TRUMP HATED HISPANICS
LIKE THE DEVIL HATES HOLLY WATER
AND SOME BELIEVED DONALD TRUMP
WAS MAKING A NATIONAL BAN ON
PICANTE SAUCE AND HISPANICS
SEEMED TO LIKE DONALD TRUMP.
COGNITIVE DIS-DANCE IS THE TERM
THAT -- DISSONANCE IS WHAT
HAPPENED NEXT.
HISPANIC VOTERS IN FLORIDA WERE
MENTALLY ILL AND ALSO EVIL.
AS ONE MIAMI HAROLD COLUMNIST
PUT IT "DONALD TRUMP'S CUBAN
AMERICAN FOLLOWERS FOLLOW FROM
CUBAN SUPREMACY SYNDROME".
THAT WAS A DIAGNOSIS.
CUBAN SUPREMACIST SERIES AND
UNKNOWN MEDICAL CONDITION LIKE
ADHD OR LONG COVID.
SOMEONE BETTER CALL A DOCTOR.
THIS COULD BE FATAL.
BEFORE THE MEDICAL ESTABLISHMENT
COULD INTERVENE TO SAVE HISPANIC
VOTERS FROM HIMSELF, THIS
AILMENT SPREAD LIKE THE VIRUS IT
WAS FIRST FROM FLORIDA AND TEXAS
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
BY 2020, IT WAS ENDEMIC.
IN THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
THAT YEAR, DONALD TRUMP, THE GUY
THAT WANTED TO BUILD A WALL
BECAME THE FIRST REPUBLICAN IN
HISTORY TO WIN SOPOTTA CAN BE
COUNTY,TEXAS.
IT'S 94% HISPANIC AND HE WON.
IT WAS A EMERGENCY MADE WORSE
THERE WERE NO CUBANS IN SUPATTO
COUNTY, TEXAS AND THAT'S WHEN A
MAN CAME TO THE RESCUE.
HE'S A BLUE-EYED COLLEGE
PROFESSOR FROM FLORIDA AND
CONVINCED NEWS ORGANIZATIONS
HE'S THE WORLD'S AUTHORITY AND
RECENTLY ARRIVING POOR PEOPLE
FROM TRAIL AMERICA REALLY THINK.
HE HAD A NEW DIAGNOSIS.
GAMARA, NBC NEWS REPORTED, FOUND
A "CASUAL LINK BETWEEN
MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION AND HOW SPANISH
SPEAKERS WHO VOTED IN RECENT
ELECTIONS".
OF COURSE IT WAS OBVIOUS, PUTIN
DID IT AND CAUSED INFLATION AND
MONKEY POX AND THE WAR IN
EUROPE.
HISPANIC VOTERS WERE TOO STUPID
TO REALIZE WHAT WAS GOING ON AND
HAD NO IDEA THEY WERE BEING
FOOLED AND WERE TOO DUMB.
TO DEMOCRATS, THIS EXPLANATION
MADE PERFECT SENSE OF COURSE AND
THEY BOUGHT IT.
A SURVEY LAST MONTH FROM WPA
INTELLIGENCE FOUND HALF OF CNN
AND NBC VIEWERS BELIEVE THAT
DISINFORMATION IS EXCELLING HIS
PAN -- COMPELLING HISPANIC
VOTERS TO VOTE REPUBLICAN.
HERE'S "FROM NBC NEWS.
>> IT'S A PHENOMENA HAVING REAL
WORLD EFFECTS AND IN FLORIDA,
40% OF CUBAN AMERICANS DON'T
BELIEVE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN WAS
LEGITIMATELY ELECTED AND GIVEN
THAT LATINOS SPEND MORE TIME ON
SOCIAL MEDIA THAN NON-HISPANIC
WHITE COUNTER PARTS, IT'S A
PROBLEM NOT GOING AWAY.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST HAPPENING IN
FLORIDA.
IN TEXAS, DEMOCRATIC STRATEGISTS
ARE SOUNDING THE ALARM ABOUT A
WAVE OF MISINFORMATION AIMED AT
LATINOS HEADING INTO 2022.
>> Tucker: DID YOU HEAR THAT?
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGISTS ARE
SOUNDING THE ALARM THAT LATINOS
SPEND SO MUCH TIME STARING
GLASSY EYED AT THEIR PHONES AND
HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
FAIRNESS OF THE LAST ELECTION.
HUH.
HOW TO FIX THIS?
OBVIOUSLY A LOT MORE SENSORSHIP
TO KEEP THIS DISINFORMATION AWAY
FROM ALL THE GULLIBLE LATINOS.
SOMEONE GET MARK ZUCKERBERG ON
THE PHONE IMMEDIATELY.
IT'S HILARIOUS.
BAD NEWS IS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IS AUTHORITARIAN AND THE GOOD
NEWS IT'S RIDICULOUS AND THAT'S
THE PEOPLE THAT BELIEVE THEIR
OWN PROPAGANDA.
THAT'S NOT THE REAL EXPLANATION.
WHAT IS THE ANSWER?
WHY ARE HISPANIC VOTERS MOVING
TO THE RIGHT?
THEY ARE.
THE LATEST FOX NEWS POLLING
SHOWS 72% OF HISPANIC VOTERS ARE
NOT SATISFIED WITH THE DIRECTION
DEMOCRATS ARE TAKING IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WHY IS THAT?
WHAT PROBLEM DO LATINO VOTERS
HAVE WITH THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
THE ANSWER MIGHT BE AS OBVIOUS
AS IT SEEMS.
THEY DON'T LIKE WHAT WE'VE GOT
NOW.
IT IS ENTIRELY POSSIBLE THAT
LIKE ALL NORMAL PEOPLE, HISPANIC
VOTERS HAVE COME TO DEPOSES THE
LIBERALS THAT RUN THEM.
DESPISE ALL THE LIBERALS THAT
RUN THEM AND NOTHING THEY SAY IS
TRUTH AND EVERYTHING THEY TOUCH
TURNS TO FILTH.
WASHINGTON DC COUNCIL MEMBER
BREANNE NADEAU PROMISED TO LOVE
AND PROTECT ILLEGAL ALIENS IN DC
AND THAT'S HOW MUCH THEY LOVE
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
YET THE MOMENT ACTUAL ILLEGAL
ALIENS SHOWED UP IN WASHINGTON
DC SENT BY THE GOVERNOR OF
TEXAS, BREANNE BECAME COMPLETELY
HYSTERICAL ABOUT IT.
WATCH THIS.
>> IT'S BEEN SAID BUT IT'S WORTH
REITERATING THAT THE GOVERNORS
OF TEXAS AND ARIZONA HAVE
CREATED THIS CRISIS AND IN MANY
WAYS, THE GOVERNORS OF TEXAS AND
ARIZONA HAVE TURNED US INTO A
BORDER TOWN.
>> Tucker: THEY'VE TURNED US
INTO A BORDER TOWN.
WHY IS THAT BAD?
WHAT'S WRONG WITH BORDER TOWNS.
WEREN'T YOU JUST SAYING HOW
GREAT BORDER TOWNS ARE AND
DIVERSITY AND STRENGTH.
IT TURNS OUT AND THIS WON'T
SHOCK YOU, SHE DIDN'T MEAN ANY
OF IT.
SHE DOESN'T WANT ILLEGAL ALIENS
IN HER NEIGHBORHOOD ANYMORE THAN
THE OVERWHELMINGLY HAS PANIC
VOTERS IN TEXAS WANT THEM IN
THEIRS.
IT MAKES HER A DISGUSTING LITTLE
HYPOCRITE.
YOU KNEW THAT ALREADY.
A LOT OF HISPANIC VOTERS ARE
LEARNING IT NOW.
THERE'S THAT.
THE BASIC REPULSIVENESS OF
DEMOCRATIC PARTY LEADERS.
BYES WAY, NEARLY ALL OF WHOM ARE
HOSTILE TO LATIN AMERICA, THAT A
LOT OF AMERICANS BELIEVE IN.
THEN THERE'S ALSO CRIME.
CRIME IS THE BIG ONE AND SEEMS
LIKELY MORE THAN ANY OTHER
ISSUE, CRIME THE INCREASE IN
CRIME IN THE UNITED STATES IS
MOVING HISPANIC VOTERS TO THE
RIGHT.
THEY SEE AS WE ALL SEE LIBERALS
ENCOURAGING CRIME AND DESTROYING
THE NEIGHBORHOOD AND DESTROYS
THE LIVES OF THE WEAKEST AND
THEY WATCH NANCY PELOSI CALL
MS13 CHILDREN OF GOD.
AT THE SAME MOMENT THAT MSNBC,
MS13 RATHER MEMBERS WERE HACK
SALVADOR AND IMMIGRANTS TO DEATH
WITH MACHETES.
>> WE'RE ALL GOD'S CHILDREN AND
A SPARK OF DIVINITY WITH EVERY
PERSON ON EARTH AND WHEN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
SAYS ABOUT UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS, THESE AREN'T PEOPLE.
THESE ARE ANIMALS.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER, DOES HE NOT
BELIEVE IN THE SPARK OF
DIVINITY, THE DIGNITY AND WORTH
OF EVERY PERSON?
>> Tucker: SO THEY WATCH
SOMEONE WHO CLEARLY DOESN'T
ACTUALLY BELIEVE IN GOD INVOKE
GOD REPEATEDLY TO DEFEND
SOMETHING THAT'S COMPLETELY
INDEFENSEABLE.
JUST A YEAR BEFORE PELOSI'S
HEART FELT TRIBUTE TO MS13 AND
MS13 GANG MEMBER STAPEDIUS STABN
OUTSIDE OF WASHINGTON AND
BEHEADED HIM AND RIPPED OUT HIS
HEART.
THAT WASN'T A CHILD OF GOD.
THAT WAS AN ANIMAL.
HISPANIC VOTERS CAN SEE THAT AND
MOST DIDN'T GO TO YALE LAW
SCHOOL TO THEIR GREAT CREDIT.
A MAN CALLED JOSE RAFAEL
LINDETTA BEHEADED A MOTHER ON
THE STREET IN SILICON VALLEY AND
HER TWO YOUNG CHILDREN WATCHED
AS HE MURDERED HER.
WHO WAS THIS MAN?
WE REACHED OUT TO THE SAN MATEO
COUNTY OFFICIAL'S AND ASKED IF
HE WAS HERE LEGALLY AND WE GOT,
"I'M SORRY, I'M NOT ABLE TO
SHARE THAT INFORMATION".
WHY IS THAT?
THERE'S A HIGH CHANCE THIS MAN
WAS IN THE GABITRIL LEGALLY.
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY AND NOT BY
ACTION.
THEY'VE SUSPENDED BORDER
ENFORCEMENT TO WIN THE LOVE 06 F
HISPANIC VOTERS AND HISPANIC
VOTERS DON'T WANT VIOLENT
LUNATICS IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD
EITHER.
THEY'RE NOT INTO BEHEADING
PEOPLE.
WHO KNEW.
THERE'S ONE OTHER FACTOR THAT
MAY BE MOVING THIS LARGE AND
CENTRALLY IMPORTANT GROUP OF
VOTERS TO THE RIGHT.
PEOPLE'S WHOSE FAMILIES
IMMIGRATED FROM THE THIRD WORLD
MAY BE MORE SENSITIVE THAN MOST
TO THE RULE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
IT'S THE ONE THING THAT AMERICA
HAS ALWAYS HAD THAT THE REST OF
THE WORLD HAS NOT.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE COME HERE AND
MOST IMMIGRANTS CONSIDER IT
IMPORTANT STILL.
LIBERALS DO NOT CONSIDER IT
IMPORTANT.
THEY'RE WORKING TO END IT.
EQUAL PROTECTION URN THE LAW IS
DISAPPEARING.
AT EVERY LEVEL OF AMERICAN LIFE,
LIBERALS APPLY AN OBVIOUS DOUBLE
STANDARD AND IT'S BASED ON RACE.
THAT'D BE MATTERS OF EDUCATION
AND EMPLOYMENT AND MATTERS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE.
LIBERALS PUT UP WITH BEHAVIOR
FROM SOME PEOPLE THEY'D NEVER
ACCEPT FROM OTHER PEOPLE AND
DEFINITION OF UNFAIRNESS BUT YOU
SEE IT EVERY SINGLE DAY.
REMEMBER THE ARREST OF THE
DOMINICAN BODEGA OWNER IN NEW
YORK WHO WAS ASSAULTED BY A MAN
WHOSE GIRLFRIEND TRIED TO ROB
THE STORE AND THE BODEGA MAN
TRIED TO DEFEND HIMSELF AND STAB
THE MAN AS MOST WOULD.
HE WAS CHARGED WITH MURDER AND
SENTENCED TO JAIL.
EVERYONE COULD TELL IT WAS A
DOUBLE STANDARD AND WOULD A
BLACK -- NO ONE SAID IT BUT
EVERYONE SAW IT.
EVERYONE UNDERSTOOD THE
UNFAIRNESS OF THAT INCLUDING
HISPANIC VOTERS.
WHY WOULD THEY LIKE IT?
IF THEY WANTED TO LIVE IN A
DEEPLY UNFAIR SOCIETY, THEY
WOULD HAVE STAYED IN THE COUNTRY
THEIR ANCESTORS CAME FROM BUT
THEY CAME HERE BECAUSE IT'S A
FAIR SOCIETY.
IT'S AN UNFAIR APPEAL AND WE'RE
ALL EQUAL UNDER THE LAW AND IT'S
THE ONE THING THAT OTHER
COUNTRIES DON'T HAVE AND WE DO
OR DID.
THERE'S A DOUBLE STANDARD AND
EVERYONE SEES IT.
IT'S NOT JUST THE LEVEL OF
BODEGA OWNERS AND GOES TO THE
VERY TOP OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
TO ITS TOP CANDIDATES AND IN
SOUTH CAROLINA FOR EXAMPLE,
DEMOCRATS HAVE NOMINATE ADD
SENATE CANDIDATE, U.S. SENATE
CALLED CRYSTAL MATTHEWS.
CRYSTAL MATTHEWS WAS CAUGHT ON
TAPE RECENTLY BY A PROJECT
VERITAS OPENLY ADVOCATES FOR
PUNISHING PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY'RE
THE WRONG SKIN COLOR.
HERE'S THE TAPE.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Tucker: GOT TO HURT WHITE
PEOPLE OR THEY WON'T REPRESENT
YOU.
SHE SAID THAT, THAT VIDEO IS
REAL.
SOMEHOW NO ONE SEEMED TO HAVE
NOTICED.
SHE'S ON THE FRONT PAGE OF THE
NEW YORK TIME THIS IS MORNING
AND NO INVESTIGATION INTO HER.
EVERYONE KNOWS IT'S WEIRD.
BUT IT'S HARDLY THE ONLY
SHOCKING NEWS STORY THAT'S NOT
BEING COVERED AS A NEWS STORY.
ALSO MISSING FROM MAINSTREAM
COVERAGE IS THIS VIDEO FROM
MEMPHIS OF YOUNG CRIMINAL
PROMISING TO MURDER WHITE PEOPLE
BECAUSE OF THEIR SKIN COLOR.
>> THE RICH OLD LADIES.
WHILE GRAND KIDS IN THE CAR.
>> Tucker: THAT VIDEO WAS
RECORDED A DAY AFTER THE
RAMPAGE, MURDER RAMPAGE IN THE
SAME CITY MEMPHIS COMMITTED BAY
FELON CALLED EZEKIEL KELLY.
HE LIKE SO MANY PEOPLE WHO
COMMITTED MURDER WAS LET OUT OF
JAIL EARLY.
BUT NO ONE IN CHARGE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN MEMPHIS
SEEMED BOTHERED BY THAT.
WHILE HE WAS KILLING PEOPLE, A
STATE REPRESENTATIVE IN
TENNESSEE, A DEMOCRAT CALLED
ANTONIO PARKINSON COMPLAINED THE
REAL PROBLEM POLICE MIGHT HURT
KELLY.
THAT WAS HIS MAIN CONCERN.
"THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE, EZEKIEL
KELLY WILL PROBABLY BE KILLED
TONIGHT AT THE HANDS OF POLICE.
WE'RE LOSING OUR CHILDREN".
REALLY?
THAT'S YOUR CONCERN.
ALL THREE OF THE STORIES WE
REMINDED YOU OUT OF, IN NEW
YORK, SOUTH CAROLINA, AND
MEMPHIS, NO ONE IS NOTICING.
JOE BIDEN'S DOJ IS STANDING BY
AND DOING NOTHING AND ALLOWING
VIOLENT RACE HATE TO FLOURISH IN
THE UNITED STATES AND THAT RACE
HATE IS THE BIGGEST CRIME WE
FACE.
ABOVE ALL ONCE AGAIN IS AN
ATTACK.
NOT ON ANY SPECIFIC ETHNIC GROUP
BUT A PRINCIPLE THAT PROTECTS
ALL OF AND YOUS THAT'S ONE OF
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
IF YOU MOVE TO THE UNITED STATES
FROM LATIN AMERICA HOPING TO
LIVE UNDER A FAIR JUSTICE
SYSTEM, THAT MIGHT BOTHER YOU.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
BOTHERED.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO LIVE IN
HONDURAS, THAT'S WHY THEY MOVED
HERE AND NO ONE IN WASHINGTON,
ON EITHER SIDE AND THE DEMOCRATS
ARE MAKING THIS POSSIBLE AND
REPUBLICANS YAMMERING ON ABOUT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM SEEM TO
UNDERSTAND THIS AND WHO
UNDERSTANDS IS IMMIGRANTS AND
UNDERSTAND THIS WELL.
IT'S NOT SAFE ANYWHERE.
ANYWHERE.
NOT JUST IN THE SO-CALLED BAD
NEIGHBORHOODS BUT THE SO CALLED
NICE NEIGHBORHOODS.
THE ONES THEY LIVE IN OR WANT TO
LIVE IN.
THIS VIDEO IS FROM SUNDAY.
IT WAS TAKEN IN A CHICAGO SUBURB
CALLED LAKE VIEW.
THREE MEN ATTACK A WOMAN ON THE
SIDEWALK IN FRONT OF HER HOME.
WATCH THIS.
[ SCREAMING ].
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT?
YOU WANT MY PHONE?
>> Tucker: YOU SEE THAT?
THAT'S NOT SOME SCARY
NEIGHBORHOOD OR ROLL THEM UP
NEIGHBORHOOD.
THAT'S THE NEIGHBORHOOD YOU LIVE
IN OR WANT TO LIVE IN.
THAT'S WHAT YOU PICTURE WHEN YOU
THINK MIDDLE AMERICA.
IT'S A NICE LEAFY NEIGHBORHOOD
AND IT'S YOUR DAUGHTER ATTACKED
ON THE SIDEWALK IN FRONT OF YOUR
HOUSE.
THAT'S HAPPENING.
IT'S GOING TO GET A LOT WORSE IF
WE DON'T PULL BACK NOW BUT
THEY'RE NOT PULLING BACK.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS DOUBLING
DOWN.
IN JANUARY POLICE IN THE STATE
OF ILLINOIS WILL BE BANNED FROM
REMOVING TRESPASSERS FROM YOUR
PROPERTY.
THE DEMOCRAT CONTROLLED
LEGISLATURE PASSED THAT LAW AND
LEGALIZED HOME INVASIONS AND
THERE'LL LIKELY BE MANY MORE OF
THOSE AND STARTING NEXT YEAR THE
SAFETY ACT JUST PASSED IN
ILLINOIS WILL LET VIOLENT FELONS
OUT OF JAIL WITH NO BAIL.
ACTUAL VIOLENT FELONS.
PEOPLE THAT COMMITTED CRIMES
LIKE SECOND DEGREE MURDER AND
ARSON AND KIDNAPPING.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN THEN?
WELL, I THINK WE NOW BECAUSE
IT'S BEEN TRIED IN OTHER PLACES
LIKE NEW YORK CITY WHERE PEOPLE
ARE REGULARLY SHOT, BEATEN AND
ROBBED IN PUBLIC.
PEOPLE WHO COULD NOT BE HELD
BEHIND BARS BECAUSE DEMOCRATS
DECIDE THAT WAS MEAN.
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT THE
CRIMINALS AND NOT WORRIED ABOUT
YOU.
AND ONCE AGAIN TO RESTATE, IF
YOU SILOED HISPANIC VOTERS INTO
THE ONE SPECIFIC GROUPS WHOSE
CONCERNS ARE DIFFERENT THAN
EVERYONE ELSE, THAT'S NOT TRUE.
HISPANICS LIKE EVERY VOTER OF
EVERY RACE.
THEY DON'T LIKE CRIME AND
VIOLENCE.
BUT IT'S EVERYWHERE.
THESE CLIPS ARE ALL FROM THE
LAST MONTH.
>> PEOPLE SITTING OUTSIDE
SUDDENLY SCRAMBLE TO GET OUT OF
THE WAY AS ONE MAN POPS OUT OF
THE SUNROOF AND ANOTHER OUT OF
PASSENGER WINDOW.
THEY BOTH START SHOOTING.
>> AN ARREST WAS MADE IN THE
BRUTAL COWARDLY SUCKER PUNCH AT
THE KING'S PLAZA MALL.  THE
21-YEAR-OLD IS FACING ASSAULT
CHARGES.
>> SURVEILLANCE FROM THE MTA BUS
CAUGHT THE INCIDENT ON AUGUST 13
AND SHOWS THE SUSPECT WALKING UP
TO A 64-YEAR-OLD VICTIM SITTING
IN THAT WHEELCHAIR.
COPS SAY HE GRABBED $250 FROM
THE MAN.
>> MAN GOT INTO A DISPUTE WITH
OTHERS AT THAT LOCATION.
ONE OF THEM HIT HIM WITH A
BASEBALL BAT AND ANOTHER PUNCHED
HIM IN THE FACE.
>> SURVEILLANCE VIDEO CAUGHT
THEM AS THEY WENT UP TO A
28-YEAR-OLD VICTIM AND HER
FRIEND.
THE TWO WERE WALKING ON THE
SIDEWALK WHEN THE DUO WENT UP TO
THEM AND TRIED TO GRAB ACCORDING
TO DETECTIVES, THE VICTIM'S
NECKLACE FROM HER NECK.
POLICE SAY THE TRIO ROAD ON TO
THE SIDEWALK AND THE PASSENGERS
FROM THE DIRT BIKE JUMPED OFF
AND FORCIBLY REMOVE ADD ROLEX
WATCH FROM THE VICTIM'S WRIST.
>> Tucker: WHAT COUNTRY IS
THIS?
IT DIDN'T USED TO BE AMERICA.
THIS IS NOT ORGANIC AND WE
DIDN'T USED TO LIVE LIKE THIS.
LIBERALS DID THIS AND ON
PURPOSE.
THEY CREATED MORE CRIME.
IT DIDN'T JUST HAPPEN AND THE
NUMBERS COULDN'T BE CLEARER ON
THAT.
ANY REPUBLICAN RUNNING FOR
OFFICE, THIS CYCLE WHICH IS TO
SAY THE MONTH AFTER NEXT, WHO
ISN'T RUNNING ON THIS IS AN
IDIOT AND EVERYONE KNOWS IT'S
HAPPENING OF ALL COLORS.
YESTERDAY LOCAL MEDIA IN NEW
YORK REPORTED THAT A 21-YEAR-OLD
TOURIST WAS KIDNAPPED AND RAPED
ON THE SUBWAY PLATFORM BY A
STRANGER.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
STOP ENFORCING THE LAW AND PUT
INTEREST OF CRIMINALS ABOVE
THOSE OF CITIZENS AND EVERYONE
CAN SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING NO